what do you love about Marvel movies
I love the fact that everybody loves
them
I I there's something that is absolutely
to be cherished I think when we have
something that people like it it's we
need more of that and I think Marvel
movies
and dceu movies are really those things
that um get people excited I mean I I
don't get as excited for Marvel movies
as a lot of people do but but I
understand their value and I think that
there's a tremendous value I mean when
Scorsese says the things he says and I
know people say hey it's not Cinema and
this and that there's so many things
that are Cinema there's two there's we
can't Define Cinema as one thing right
it's only this it's only a small Art
House film
um no it's it's not it can it can be a
Marvel film as long as it again I still
I still want to see a very
singular directorial artistic Vision on
the film and I think that's where the
Marvel films sometimes lose their value
is when I watch when you have Chloe Zhao
coming in and doing eternals and when
you watch eternals and having obviously
recently seen Nomad land and then the
writer I mean the writer uh one of my
favorite films of the past decade when
you look at what's her talent and what
she does and then when you watch
eternals you don't see this same you can
see that someone came in and said listen
we love what you're doing but we're
gonna we need to put this in the Marvel
world so we can't let you go full Chloe
We Can't Let You Go full uh you know
whoever even rainy recently I think when
you watch Multiverse Madness you see
some parts that are Sam Raimi then you
see other parts that aren't you see
other parts that almost feel like it's
from someone else and I think that's the
challenge and those are the things that
for me are the the hardest thing for a
Marvel movie is I wish that Marvel would
allow their directors to really impart
their Vision their individual singular
Vision on a film and an eternal is the
perfect example of that it just you
don't see Chloe like you do in Nomad
land the writer you don't see that
organic filmmaker
um you just you see it so sparingly in
the film that you wonder where she
disappears to right in the process of
the filmmaking and I think that's the
challenge as a filmmaker when you step
into certainly an MCU film I think
Warner Brothers does a much better job
of allowing their directors a cart
launch in what they're going to do you
look at Joker and what Todd Phillips did
with that film would Marvel ever allow
that no there's no chance Marvel would
never Kevin feige would never let them
make a film like Joker if Joker were in
the Marvel Universe and Todd Phillips
said hey I want to make this super dark
king of comedy meets Taxi Driver version
of Joker Kevin feigen say no no way in
hell Warner Brothers said yes
I think Marvel would be better served if
it allowed its directors to do what Todd
Phillips did with Joker to go all out
and let that director really go after it
um and I think that's the challenge I
think as a filmmaker when you go work
for for Marvel you know that you're
going to be lost uh you at least you
better be aware of it now from watching
eternals go back multiple uh Dr Strange
soup when you're a filmmaker and you go
in and you you look at at uh what Marvel
does with their films you don't see the
director as often and I think that that
is I think going forward if I was a
director
who really wanted to have my vision of a
film up on the screen I don't think I
would work for Marvel because I think
they're going to
dampen your impact
immeasurably
so you see the executive's note when you
watch no question a Marvel oh yeah when
you you see uh listen Marvel's a is a
listen they're the five billion pound
gorilla when it comes to to cinema these
days and Kevin feige obviously has a
very specific plan that is working for
them largely but as we get here into
phase four you're seeing some films like
eternals even strange let's hope that
Thor love and thunder is is stronger I
think that it's interesting as I say all
that I feel like taika waititi is given
more artistic Freedom with his visions
of those Thor films than a lot of the
filmmakers but he's earned that too you
gotta remember obviously this is now
going to be his third or is the second
third or third he's gonna be he's been
in the system so I think he's earned
more trust but um but I think that that
when you look at these Marvel films I
think you absolutely see the studio
notes and versus the True full wattage
director
artistic Vision that you see in a lot of
these directors other films
is there a comic book character that was
either made better or made worse in the
film version so either way I did the the
comic book version was was one thing and
then the film became it comes down to
two performances for me the two
performances
um it's really about the actor and the
role there's there's a lot that have
been nailed I think that's true but I
think there's two without question
Robert Downey Jr is Ironman and Hugh
Jackman is Wolverine those are two
performances as those comic book
characters that frankly can never be
recast I don't think there's a way that
you could ever have someone else play
either Iron Man or Wolverine and get
away with it because they have cemented
their legacy as just iconic what they've
done with those characters I would never
want to try to step into those shoes
because it's it's virtually impossible
and I think those two in particular are
the absolute best of the best
um that said you know you go back and
look at you look at Joker I mean you
look at all the different ver Heath
leather
um Heath Ledger Joker you go obviously
Joaquin Phoenix Joker you're looking at
two great Jokers uh so there's you can I
think it depends on the character
um but at this point again with with
let's say both Wolverine and Iron Man
we've seen so much of Robert Downey Jr a
decade plus going back to you know truly
Marvel's first film in Iron Man
um that it's just a legacy that uh will
never go no one will ever touch that I
mean he is I think look at look at this
way Robert Downey Jr's performance is
Iron Man
elevated Iron Man from a mid Marvel
character right let's just say mid to
truly the Mount Rushmore of Marvel
characters I mean you or Comic Book
Heroes in general comic book characters
you're talking about Superman Batman
Spider-Man and Iron Man those are my
four Wonder Woman five okay five on the
thing right and and obviously gal has
done a tremendous job even though Wonder
Woman 84 oh what a horrible film uh but
she's great the casting's right
um but but I think that that the way
that Robert Downey Jr elevated Iron Man
to this character that really again was
a mid Marvel character that's Robert
Downey Jr it's all him if you put
someone else in that film do we even
have the MCU like we we did I don't know
the answer to that if someone else plays
Iron Man
less iconically than Robert Downey Jr
did from the original all the way
through I don't think it's the same
Legacy I don't see how it's possible
he's so he was born to be Iron Man even
though I think he's graded everything he
does and he really needs to be working
in independent film if I was Robert
Downey Jr's agent I'd be like listen man
you need to be working with a24 you need
to be working with neon make some small
independent film he's a tremendous actor
I think people forget that about Robert
Downey Jr
um tremendously smart guy too if you
listen to interviews from him God
brilliant man
um but but I think people lose the fact
that that he is I think he's he might be
the singular reason why Marvel is the
way is what it is Robert Downey Jr so he
took sort of a mid-tier comic book
character and made it top shelf no
question I mean again Iron Man was no
one back in even let's go back to the
mid 2000s before Iron Man and you say
name uh comic book characters people
would not throw out Iron Man no way they
would throw out Hulk obviously
Spider-Man Batman the traditional
Superman no one would say Ironman now
they would now now you would and I think
that's going to be the challenge going
forward too because now that he's gone
and I I by the way do not bring that
character back okay you I as as tempting
as it is as much trouble as you get into
let's just assume that the MCU starts to
really go on a down slide do not ever
bring him back I don't care if it not in
the Multiverse nothing that's a perfect
ending to a to a character and and
you're gonna tarnish the Legacy and and
I think that will be a challenge because
ultimately if if you struggle you're
like well how can we get everyone back
well let's bring back Robert Downey Jr
um I'm sure he'd do it for the right
amount of money he made so much cash
playing that character but I think
artistically it's the wrong choice and
for legacy it's the wrong choice so I
hope it doesn't happen
why do you think comic book movies
dominate The Box Office
that's good um
I think ultimately films are about
accessibility
certainly for audience and the larger
that your
pie chart is for the given film Marvel
obviously dominates like almost the
entire pie of of available moviegoers
right so you're looking at a four quad
film which means young old male female
everybody's in right families especially
so that's the reason Marvel was so
successful is obviously it's four quad
obviously you're talking about a film
that appeals to families superheroes
escapism it's got all these things going
for it that it's very easy to understand
why it's successful that said after
watching Multiverse and Madness and
going back to eternals you're you're
looking at Marvel being in a spot where
they really need Thor love and thunder
to be not good they needed to be
borderline great or better because
you're at a spot where I think people
are starting to go I mean you've seen
the the chatter on social media people
are saying I'm kind of overcoming with
movies I'm not as excited now as I was
and I think that's the challenge is how
do we recreate how do we get that going
again and
um for me again the answer is very
simple is allow these directors
to make the film they want to make
without
the overriding studio notes slash MCU
Kevin feige saying this is what we're
doing trust in your filmmaker to deliver
something that will re-energize the fan
base and when you look at Joker and Todd
Phillips granted it's completely apart
from the dceu but either way it's still
connected and look what that film did a
billion worldwide a film that people
were like what are we doing with an
R-rated CBM and it turns out to be
obviously an Oscars player Oscar's
winner and and a film that really
re-energized I think DC even if it's
disconnected but why because they allow
the director to make the film that he
wanted to make and most Studios wouldn't
do that Warner Brothers would get so
much crap for you know what happened
with Zack Snyder and I understand things
happen nothing's perfect in the studio
world but you have to give Warner
Brothers the credit they are due for
Taking Chances and we need more Studios
to take chances we lost Fox as you guys
know you know 20th century is now part
of Disney Fox was kind of doing their
own thing Deadpool and now that that's
gone you're you lost an entire Studio
that used to take chances like Fox did a
great job of doing that
um and now that's under the Disney
umbrella we'll see what happens I know
they're gonna make a Deadpool three will
it be in the same irreverent super R
hard R uh CBM that we've expected I
think the answer is yes because you
can't do that any other way but Studios
Taking Chances we we need more of that
and Warner Brothers does that
four quad you said it's young old so
four quad so yeah four quad film is is a
film that appeals basically to everybody
right so when you talk about a four quad
film you're talking about something that
when you look at the movie going pie
available audience of this pie chart
you're talking about pretty much the
entire pie chart filled in with one
giant slice of the movie going public
that will go see your film and you're
talking about young old uh male female
it's everybody right so so that's those
are Marvel films that's Jurassic world
Dominion that's
um you know it's not every film
certainly but the films those are the
films that are going to do the best at
the box office Maverick top go Maverick
is a four quad film even though it
probably is a little bit lesser on the
younger but you know the screening I
went to to show you how four quad this
is I sit down last Thursday when the
film opens here I am at Top Gun Maverick
I sit down on my seat four o'clock
screening on a Thursday on my right is a
woman that's probably in her mid 80s and
on my left a family with two young kids
under the age of five so you've got five
to eighty five right and someone in the
middle right there and it's just like
this is this is the whole pie this is
the four quad and you see it in action
and uh not every film is going to be
that way but but Marvel is and uh and
most Summer Films are going to be four
o'clock because they know the kids are
out of school Pixar yeah Pixar certainly
light year uh the Pixar would be a four
quad film
um you know any of those usually
traditionally you're going to see those
at Christmas you're gonna see them at
over the summer when you know you have
those kids available to you all day for
the matinees and all that stuff but but
yeah those are the films are gonna do
the best